since this is a 1980s movie about frack
brothers there has to be a scene about
dudes getting it on with an animal
i don't know how we're going to be able
to release this on youtube oh my god
welcome back to laws broken the series
where a real lawyer pulverizes your
pleasant movies from the 1980s by
showing you how illegal everything is
because everything is illegal i'm sure
most of you have probably watched
revenge of the nerds at one time or
another well specifically you probably
watched it at 3 o'clock the morning on
tbs since that's the only time slot
where 80s frat boy comedies were allowed
to air albeit in highly edited form and
you might not remember all of the laws
that were broken in revenge of the nerds
but i assure you there were a lot of
them because the main fixation of these
type of movies is of course
girls
there's 6
127 students at adams
58 of which are girls so
so that's 7
107.32 boobs and thankfully we've come a
long time since this movie was released
yes revenge of the nerds is from another
era before nerds were celebrated part of
the zeitgeist and they had their own
award-winning tv shows
sarcasm
you think but in 1984 people were not so
sensitive to the plight of the nerds
hence we got revenge of the nerds a
movie about a group of criminal
degenerates and their plea for tolerance
so the crime kicks off with what may be
an actual murder as lewis and gilbert
the lead nerds walk through their atoms
college for the first time they walk
right by the alpha beta fraternity this
sets up what is probably the most quoted
line from the movie
yes ogre takes one look at the pair of
computer junkies and lets out a primal
roar
as one does this sets lewis and gilbert
on edge as they realize that they are
subjects of intense derision what they
don't seem to notice is that ogre is
dangling a man from the roof and that
man then presumably drops 30 or more
feet to the ground did he die did he
just break his neck did we just watch a
murder take place in the first five
minutes of this movie well the movie
takes place at adams college a fictional
college somewhere in the midwest since
i've never picked on nebraska before
let's pick on nebraska i'm setting the
movie smack dab in the middle of the
cornhusker state and in nebraska a
person commits murder in the first
degree if he or she kills another person
one purposefully with deliberate and
premeditated murder or two in the
perpetration or the attempt to
perpetrate any other first-degree felony
i'm gonna go out on a limb and say that
there just aren't many circumstances
that justify intentionally dangling a
person off of a roof first degree murder
carries a potential life sentence if the
person dies but if there's just an
attempt then it's a class two felony
which carries a penalty of up to 50
years in prison i think ogre is probably
gonna get out in 25 with good behavior
now the plot so to speak really takes
off when the alphas accidentally burned
down their fraternity house in their
defense who knew the plane with a zippo
and drinking 180 proof whiskey could
lead to an actual fire so is this arson
well probably not a person only commits
first-degree arson if they intentionally
set fire to a structure or start a fire
while in the process of committing
another felony the fire starter here
appears to be a guy named haystack i
guess that explains this movie's choice
to put him in overalls but at any rate
he didn't intentionally set the fire
accident is generally a defense to arson
but he might also be able to plead
diminished capacity because of extreme
intoxication now intoxication is another
version of a diminished capacity defense
involuntary intoxication is when someone
drugs you or you take something that you
didn't expect to react to but voluntary
intoxication is when you really do mean
to get drunk and of course you succeed
now getting drunk on purpose is not a
defense on its own otherwise we could
all just get drunk and commit crimes
without consequence however if you're so
wasted that you can't control your
actions then it might mean that
prosecutors would have a hard time
proving that you set the fire
intentionally so based on these defenses
it might be that haystack is safe from
charges of first degree arson but that
doesn't mean that everyone is completely
off the hook the guys tell the fire
department that the fire was caused by
some faulty wiring this is probably a
misstep it's definitely a crime to lie
to law enforcement authorities nebraska
law calls these false reporting quote a
person commits an offense of false
reporting if he or she a furnishes
material information he or she knows to
be false to any peace officer or other
official with the intent to instigate an
investigation of an alleged criminal
matter or to impede the investigation of
an actual criminal matter this is a
class one misdemeanor now the alpha
betas face up to one year in jail and or
a thousand dollar fine for false
reporting but shout out to a young john
goodman as the football coach who helps
the guys get alternative housing there
is of course a big game coming up and he
doesn't want them worrying about where
they're going to live the dean
acquiesces to this plan which then leads
to the next scenes where the alphas are
storming the freshman dormitory and
throwing everyone out so as of now that
dorm is ours right any room you want
ready
these guys are probably the same ones 35
years later would storm the capital and
basically do the same thing ogre then
throws a man out the window now just
because the dean consented to the plan
doesn't mean that the way that they
moved into the dorms was legal throwing
a guy out the window is still assault
and battery and more precisely it's
defenestration defenestration is one of
my favorite words in the english
language it's the act of throwing
someone out a window now in the past
defenestration has ignited multiple wars
including the bohemian revolt against
the habsburg emperor ferdinand ii which
started the 30 years war back in 1618.
now here in america deep fenestration is
usually just considered aggravated
battery charles barkley once famously
heaved a man through a glass window
after the man harassed several people at
a bar barkley said what he did was
inappropriate i'm going to defend myself
let there be no debate if you bother me
i'm going to whip your ass the guy threw
ice in my face and i slammed his ass
into the window let it ever be said that
charles barkley doesn't have a way with
words now barkley was charged with
aggravated battery but the case was
dropped after the man who got thrown
through the window declined to prosecute
that happened after he signed a
settlement with sir charles now in
nebraska the state charges this as an
assault crime quote a person commits the
offense of assault in the first degree
if he or she intentionally or knowingly
causes serious bodily injury to another
person first degree assault is a class 2
felony class 2 felonies carry a possible
punishment of up to 50 years in prison
but i think the outcome here depends a
lot on whether the victim was seriously
hurt or just banged up ogre probably got
first degree assault
let's say 10 years but let's focus now
on the nerds the nerds are now homeless
and seeking a fraternity so betty chiles
the leader of the mean girls intervenes
to send them to the alpha betas where
they will be humiliated well tell us
what frat do you think is us
you guys are alpha betas all the way
since this is a 1980s movie about frack
brothers there has to be a scene about
dudes getting it on with an animal here
is that scene you guys seem pretty cool
take these for later
rubbers
what do we need rubbers for
okay that is more than enough of that
scene we don't actually see gilbert and
louis fornicating with the sheep but if
they did that is the crime of indecency
with an animal quote a person commits
indecency with an animal when such
person subjects an animal to sexual
penetration as defined in section 28-318
lewis and gilbert therefore indecency
with an animal as a class 3 misdemeanor
get up to 3 months in jail and or a 500
fine now in our next scene it features
multiple instances of the cinema sin of
racial stereotyping where frat bro has
takashi if he knows karate and then he
puts a jock strap on his head you know
karate i know good
now under nebraska law in 1984 this is
simple assault at best misdemeanor
assault is assault in the third degree
and consists of either intentionally
knowingly or recklessly causing bodily
injury to another person or threatening
another in a menacing manner now takashi
isn't seriously hurt so this isn't a
felony case but 21st century bullies
beware because in 1997 nebraska passed a
hate crimes law that enhances criminal
penalties when a person commits an
offense because of someone's race color
religion ancestry national origin gender
sexual orientation age or disability if
found guilty of a hate crime under the
law it acts as a penalty enhancement
this means that a person will be
punished for the next level of offense
so if you were to use a racial slur or
ask a guy if he knows karate before
choking him with his own jock strap
expect prosecutors to consider a penalty
enhancement so random frat guy the
penalty in this case would be up to six
months in jail a fine of up to one
thousand dollars or both luckily for
this guy canceled culture hasn't arrived
in 1984 so this guy can probably just
get off with probation now in the next
scene louis inadvertently invents
apartments.com zillow and airbnb
okay i programmed him with all the
rental units in the area and the
computer he built looks totally like
it's related to the dogs you don't see
it well just wait until you see it in
action later on now louis's zillow
moment brings us to this scene where
worms are the 13 year old goes to one of
the apartments and is hit on by an adult
woman hi
i came about the room for rent
it's right next to mine
it'll be perfect for us why yes she did
answer the door wearing a negligee and
she immediately offers the boy sex
things that would only happen in a 1980s
frat movie now this is probably criminal
child enticement quote no person by any
means and without privilege to do so
shall solicit coax entice or lure or
attempt to solicit coke's entice or lure
any child under the age of 14 years into
any place with the intent to seclude the
child from his or her parent guardian or
the legal custodian or the general
public whether or not the person knows
the age of the child the prospective
landlady arguably tried to entice
wormser into the house in violation of
the law she's guilty of a class 3a
felony class 3a felonies carry a
possible punishment of up to three years
in prison and an 18-month post-release
supervision and or up to a ten thousand
dollar fine and is it also contributing
to the delinquency of a child well under
section
28-709 of the nebraska criminal code any
person who by any act encourages causes
or contributes to the delinquency or
need for special supervision of a child
under 18 years of age so the child
becomes or will tend to become a
delinquent child or a child in need of
special supervision commits contributing
to the delinquency of a child now
there's a lot of gray area about what it
means for a child to quote tend to
become delinquent worms or isn't a child
in need of special supervision in fact
he's actually a genius but the statute
doesn't require that the child actually
become delinquent or need special
supervision but only that the defendant
encouraged the child to become
delinquent or to need special
supervision so that the child will quote
tend to become a delinquent child or a
child in need of special supervision so
let's say this lane lady is getting
slapped with six months in jail for her
tendency to create a delinquent child
and then of course the computer that he
created basically goes off and becomes a
dalek even attacking a human being now
when the newly minted trilam's plan a
party they struggle to get dates and
this is where the movie takes a turn
from revenge of the nerds into revenge
of the incels of course booger has been
searching for dates at the local high
school if any of you guys got dates
besides gilbert i do
yeah but that's with a guy
what about you booger i've been out
combing the high schools all day and
although we don't see his conduct if we
take him at his word he's potentially
broken several laws first is stalking
which is defined as being willfully
harassed intentionally terrified
threatened or intimidated by individuals
who intentionally follow detain stalk or
harass them harassing behavior occurs
when someone engages in conduct that
quote seriously terrifies threatens or
intimidates the person and which serves
no legitimate purpose this is a class
one misdemeanor unless the victim is
under 16 years old when it becomes a
felony so booger is almost certainly
facing up to a year in jail and or a
thousand dollar fine just for stalking
these teen girls now after the frat boys
and girls continue to mock the nerds the
nerds formulate a plan for revenge the
nerds decide not to commit violence
against the alphas because that would
only bring them down to their level so
instead
they decide to commit violence against
the women i know what we're gonna do
or in this movie's parlance they decide
to have a fun panty raid these are the
protagonists of this movie remember so
let me give you a rundown of all the
crimes in this particular scene first
there's burglary a person commits
burglary of such person willfully
maliciously or forcibly breaks and
enters any real estate or any
improvements erected thereon with the
intent to commit any felony the men
broke in with the intent of chasing down
naked women and planting video cameras
on the premises i think that probably
qualifies as having the intent to commit
a felony now in nebraska burglary can be
charged as either a class 2 or class 3
felony depending on the circumstances of
the case class 2 felony nebraska is
punishable by up to 50 years in prison
while a class iii felony is punishable
by up to four years in prison so let's
pretty much just throw the book at lewis
and give him 50 years in prison for
committing burglary in order to commit a
whole bunch of sex crimes then of course
there is the guilt of first degree
criminal trespass a person commits
first-degree criminal trespass if he or
she quote enters or secret remains in
any building or occupied structure or
any separately secured or occupied
portion thereof knowing that he or she
is not licensed or privileged to do so
this is a first degree misdemeanor that
probably will not carry more than three
to six months in jail and then here's
lewis terrifyingly just hiding in the
shower then jumping out yelling panty
raid and then chasing the naked girls
down the hall
today this would have ended with olivia
benson taking the perp to jail but in
1984 it was played for laughs but lewis
may be guilty of second or third degree
sexual assault quote any person who
subjects another to sexual contact
without consent of the victim is guilty
of sexual assault in either the second
or third degree and what is sexual
contact you probably didn't ask well
that is defined as quote the intentional
touching of the victim's sexual or
intimate parts or the intentional
touching of the victim's clothing
covering the immediate area of the
victim's sexual or intimate parts now
unfortunately for the victims here
sexual assault is only a class one
misdemeanor if the perpetrator didn't
cause serious personal injury now did
lewis touch any of these women we don't
know but clearly he was attempting to do
that third degree sexual assault is a
class one misdemeanor which carries a
possible penalty up to one year in jail
and a fine of one thousand dollars and
while the girls scream the nerds
congratulate themselves on their crimes
the nerds then install video cameras in
the sorority house and then do terrible
things with that tape this is behavior
that nowadays would have gotten them
labeled as sex offenders for life but
it's definitely an invasion of privacy
so what laws do they break in addition
to breaking and entering sexual assault
and trespass well under nebraska
criminal section 28-311
it shall be unlawful for any person to
knowingly intrude upon any other person
without his or her consent in a place of
solitude or seclusion now that's a
misdemeanor but they also violated
section 2 which states it shall be
unlawful for any person to knowingly and
intentionally photograph film or
otherwise record an image or video of an
intimate area of another person without
his or her knowledge and consent this is
a class 4 failing the maximum penalty is
2 years imprisonment and two months
post-release supervision and a ten
thousand dollar fine or both so all of
them including the thirteen-year-old
wormser are looking at a two-year prison
sentence for unlawful intrusion and of
course later they violate section three
of that criminal code by selling
photographs of naked women it shall be
unlawful for any person to knowingly and
intentionally distribute or otherwise
make public an image or video of another
person recorded in violation of section
2 of this section without that person's
consent this is a class 2a felony with a
20-year maximum prison sentence and when
this movie was released there was no sex
offender registry but today if the men
were over 19 and any victim was under
the age of 18 they'd be required to
register under the sex offender
registration act and they also allowed
the 13 year old wormser to watch these
videos which probably contributed to the
endangerment of a minor and please note
that the girls were fighting off the
nerds and this is mostly in self-defense
under today's laws under most states
these days they probably would have been
justified in just shooting these guys
dead for home invasion and then finally
capping off the biggest crimes we have
that time that lewis
betty yeah you heard me lewis puts on a
darth vader mask impersonates stan and
has sex with stan's girlfriend betty now
sex through deception is but it's not
always punishable as a crime depending
on how the jurisdiction defines consent
by fraud was first recognized in
american criminal law in 1865 in
michigan in the people versus crosswell
there the michigan supreme court upheld
the defendant's conviction for by fraud
and stated quote the outrage upon the
woman is just as great in these cases as
if actual force had been employed that's
because the women didn't consent to sex
with that particular man which is the
same situation we have here and of
course there are always going to be
people defending the scene by alleging
that in 1984 no one knew it was wrong
but that's kind of like saying that in
the 18th century no one knew that
slavery was wrong it definitely people
knew in fact it was a crime back then so
it's hard to say that
everything was hunky-dory back then and
here to add insult to injury betty is
actually happy with deception and leaves
stan for lewis that was wonderful
he did things to me you've never done
before and critics at the time didn't
even seem to be bothered by this jean
siskel loved it he called the
characterization of the two sweet and
although roger ebert listed the panty
raid scene as one part of the movie that
could put the boys in a bad light he
called the movie great because of the
human element there's a human element
underlying this film that makes it
interesting the story of these of these
nerds i don't know how we're going to be
able to release this on youtube oh my
god
and here's a quick rundown of the minor
laws broken in this movie the football
team assaults gilbert the coach
participates even threatening to break
his neck attempted assault here the frat
guy is moon the try lambs this is public
indecency the person commits public
indecency if such person exposes quote
the generals of the body done with the
intent to affront or alarm any person
it's a class 2 misdemeanor and that
would get these guys up to six months in
jail and fine the frat bros and frat
girls steal a farm truck and then turn
the pigs loose on the nerd's house at
simple theft and vandalism punishable by
up to a year in jail the jocks placed a
burning nerd sign in front of the lawn
vandalism three to six months in jail
the nerds drip some heat rub oil on the
alpha's jock straps is that a crime you
bet it is that's assault and let's talk
about the prison sentences for the two
worst characters in this movie it was
written with only one main bad guy ogre
but louis is also just as bad if not
worse ogre probably gets 25 years in
jail for attempted murder and 15 for
defenestration that's 40 years in jail
and the ultimate perp of this movie
lewis will probably go to prison for by
deception let's say 20 years for that
he's also guilty of two counts of
unlawful intrusion for entering and
helping with filming which is four more
years add to that 50 years for burglary
one year for assaulting the girls in the
hallway his total sentence is probably
somewhere around 60 to 75 years now this
video isn't over as you can imagine
there are a lot more crimes that the
nerds committed but it's too hot
disgusting to go on youtube but you can
watch the extended version over on
nebula and i'm thrilled to announce my
first nebula original bad law words good
it's a long form documentary where i
explore all the most common legal and
linguistic ideas that people threw
around in everyday life incorrectly so
strap in because it's gonna get really
pedantic it's a hilarious romp through
legal misunderstandings logical
fallacies and law and order parodies and
it's only available on nebula because
nebula is a place where we can
experiment with content and do things
that we couldn't put on youtube and
we're thrilled to be partnering with
curiosity stream because they are the
go-to source for the best documentaries
and long-form educational content on the
internet they even have an entire
section devoted to unsolved mysteries
and crime so if you like my videos you
will love the stuff on curiositystream
and we've worked out a deal where if you
sign up for curiositystream with the
link in the description you'll also get
a nebula subscription for free and to be
clear that nebula subscription is not a
trial it's free for as long as you're a
curiosity stream member and right now
curiosity stream is offering 26 off
their annual plans that's less than 15
for the entire year for both curiosity
stream and nebula so if you click on the
link that's on screen right now you'll
get curiosity stream and nebula for 26
off or you can go to curiositystream.com
legaleagle it's a great way to support
this channel and educational content
directly for under 15 per year so if you
want a huge discount on curiosity stream
and nebula just click on the link that's
on screen right now or the link that's
in the description plus clicking on that
link really helps out this channel and
while you're there click on this
playlist with all of my other laws
broken and legal reactions so click on
this playlist or i'll see you in court